(bright music)
- What is in-context learning?
Slightly related to the previous question
and thinking about the kinds of things
that language models can do,
or especially that we
were surprised to see
that language models can do.
Maybe one of the most
surprising was this phenomenon
called in-context learning
where if I take a little
machine learning data set
and I just feed it to the
language model, right?
So I give it a movie review
and then the star rating
that was assigned to
the movie by the critic,
and then another movie
review and the star rating
that was assigned to
that movie by the critic,
and you give just a couple
of examples of these things.
Language models generate the ability
both to generate plausible
sounding movie reviews,
but also to predict the star ratings
that should come after them, right?
And more generally, if I have
a machine learning problem.
I have my inputs and my outputs,
I put some inputs and outputs
as input to the model,
I give it one more input and I
ask it to predict the output,
models can often do this really well.
And this is a super interesting,
fundamentally different way
of doing machine learning, right,
where I have this one
big general purpose model
into which I can insert
lots of little machine
learning data sets and yet,
without having to train
a new model at all,
classifier or a generator or whatever
specialized to my particular task.
This is actually something
we've been thinking a lot
about in my group and
in some collaborations
with colleagues at Google
trying to understand exactly
how this in-context learning phenomenon
actually comes about.
What are your thoughts
on the potential of LLMs,
should people be scared,
excited, or somewhere in between?
I think the answer is
somewhere in between.
Certainly, in the short-term,
the thing that I'm most scared about
has to do with these sort of truthfulness
and coherence issues that I
was mentioning before, right?
That even the best
models that we have today
do generate incorrect facts,
they generate code with bugs,
and sort of because of
the way these models work,
they do so in a way that's
particularly difficult
for humans to spot
because the model output
has all the right surface statistics.
And so when we think about code,
I think it's still an open question,
whether it's actually less work
for somebody to write a function by hand
or to ask language model
to generate that function
and then have the person go through
and verify that the
implementation of that function
was actually correct.
And I think there's a
little danger in rushing
to deploy these tools right away
that will wind up in a world
where everything's a little bit worse
where it's actually very
difficult for people
to actually reliably check
the outputs of these models.
That being said,
I think these are problems
that can be overcome.
I think the pace that things
are moving at especially,
there's a lot of room
to address these issues
of factuality and
coherence and correctness
of generated code and things like that.
And that in the long term,
these really are tools I
think for freeing ourselves up
as a society from a lot of sort
of unpleasant or drudge work
that has been difficult to automate,
and that that's something
to be excited about.
How to deal with ethics issues
if generative AI generate data
and the fake data is misused in some way?
We deal with these ethics
issues in the same way
that we've always done
with legal processes
and societal processes
and governmental processes
that are designed to address them.
At the end of the day,
people are using these systems, right?
They're not fully autonomous,
there are people who are
responsible for their inputs,
responsible for their outputs,
responsible for their behaviors.
And I think thinking that,
the sort of issues associated
with the ethical deployment
of these technologies is
something that we as technologists
can solve is really misguided.
And that in fact, there are
already sophisticated structures
in place in our societies and cultures
for dealing with factual issues,
for dealing with generation of untruths
or unreliable or incorrect
outputs or bad machine decisions.
And that we really need to think
about strengthening these systems
rather than trying to come up
with technological solutions
or purely technological solutions.
Why do LLMs tend to hallucinate facts
that is confidently assert
things that are not true,
and does that limit the
usefulness of these models
for applications where
factual accuracy is important?
We've alluded to this hallucination
issue a couple of times,
and I think why it happens is
still partly an open question.
But if I had to guess,
right, just architecturally,
there are reasons that
these big transformer models
that it's hard for these models
to build coherent models
of the world, right?
And they can do that a little bit.
You can sort of query them
with factual questions,
trivia questions, and they get
'em right most of the time,
maybe even more often
than your average human
user off the street.
But unlike your average human user,
it's really unclear
whether there's anything
that lives inside this language model
that corresponds to a belief
about the state of the world.
And I think this is both
for architectural reasons,
that just transformers don't
obviously have anywhere
to put that belief, and training data,
that these models are
trained on the internet
which was authored by a
bunch of different people
at different moments who
believe different things
about the state of the world,
and therefore it's
difficult to expect models
to represent those things coherently.
All that being said,
I don't think this is a
fundamental limitation
of neural language models
or even more general
language models in general
but something that's true
about today's language models,
we're already seeing that models
are sort of approaching being able
to build representations of fact,
representations of the state of the world,
and I think there's
room to improve further.
Is it ethical for these
systems to use the first person
when interacting with users?
Should they respond with,
"As an AI language model, I,"
or something like this generative
text prediction system?
This is a great question.
So I certainly believe that
it's very, very, very important
for deployed versions of
these systems to make it clear
to users that they're interacting
with some automated
decision making process
and not an actual human
user on the other end,
and that kind of transparency
is really fundamental for getting people
to trust these systems and
understand their limitations.
I don't think it's necessarily a problem
for these models to use the word I,
that they don't have
to refer to themselves
as this generative text
prediction system every time.
I think we're already used to dealing
with personal assistance
like Siri or Alexa or Cortana
that refer to themselves
in the first person.
But I think there are ways of doing that
while still making it
extremely clear to the user
and maybe reminding them periodically
that what they're interacting
with is not a person.
Is it possible for LLMs
to contain mini neural networks within
and adaptively use these
mini neural networks
for in-context learning?
This is a great question
and related to the
in-context learning question
that we had before.
And so I'll give specifically
a shout out to my student,
in Accurex work in collaboration
with folks at Google,
Amy answered exactly this question
and showing that at least in principle,
it is possible for
transformer language models
to train mini machine
learning models inside of them
and simulate that training process
and use the embedded
models to make predictions.
Whether this is actually what's going on
in the larger scale models
that we have right now
is an empirical question,
whether that little mini model
that's getting simulated
during in-context learning,
is it transformer, or something smaller,
or something simpler, something different?
All still unknown, but this
is an active area of research,
and one that I'm
particularly excited about.
Is it possible that an LLM is fine tuned
with other kinds of data,
for example, time series
data and perform well?
Yeah, so this is also a great question.
And I think right now when people think
about applying language
models to other kinds,
data in other modalities,
other problem domains,
they are thinking about
converting those problem domains
into text querying the
language model in tech space
and then getting the answers back out.
But this is not the only
thing that you can do
and it's definitely
possible to take a model
that's been pre-trained on language data
and fine tune it on data
and other modalities.
And what's especially
interesting there is that,
if you succeed at doing this right,
then that tells you
that the language model
is learned something,
not just about language,
but about kind of structured
data sets in general.
So here at MIT, one version
of this that we've done,
my group in collaboration
with Antonio Torralba's group
and actually also some folks at Nvidia,
is look specifically at what happens
when you take language
models and fine tune them
on robot demonstrations.
And there you do actually
really seem to get improvements
in model's ability to sort of generalize
to new tasks and new goals.
And I think that's some evidence
that pre-training on language data
tells you something not
just about language,
but about structure in general.
LLMs are getting a lot
of attention right now,
but what other new AI or ML models
are also seeing meaningful progress
and should we keep in
mind in the coming years?
In terms of sort of basic
neural network architectures
that we have for solving
prediction problems,
these sort of like one token at a time,
what are called auto regressive models
are the rage in NLP right now.
But people who work with
other kinds of data modalities
still use different kinds of models.
Obviously, in image generation land,
there's a huge amount of
interest in diffusion models
that underlie a lot of the
image generation results
that people are seeing right now.
There's still a lot of use of
convolutional neural networks,
and recently, there's been
quite a bit of interest
in looking at ways of applying tools
that people use right now mostly
for working with image data
and using them to work
with text data instead.
And I guess looking a bit past
the low level neural modeling questions
that a lot of people are
thinking about right now,
it wouldn't actually surprise me
if we see a return to
some of the more explicit
structured approaches that
were at least more predominant
in a previous generation
of NLP approaches, right?
So there's this whole long tradition
of formal representations
of meanings of sentences
basically as chunks of code
that you can sort of answer a user's query
by not just pulling the
answer to that query
out of a language model
but translating it into a database query
or something even more abstract,
a little computer program
that you can run and
execute to get answers out.
And one of the things
that's really appealing
about language models
or language to code models in particular
is that they actually make
it a lot easier to implement
a lot of these kind of classical
structured approaches, right?
So if you sort of take very
seriously linguistic theories
about how sentences
ought to get represented,
now you can implement those
theories computationally
not by sort of spending an entire PhD
handcrafting some kind of model,
but just by showing a language model.
A couple of examples of
the kind of representation
that you're interested in.
So thinking back to what we said before
about language models
maybe not being great
at building models of the world
or solving really complicated computation
or inference problems, there,
I think there's actually a lot of room
to use language models
just as a building block
in more complicated systems
or more sophisticated systems
that map from language to to code
or other kinds of structured
representations of meaning
as a stepping stone towards final answers.
If GPT-5 was a student of yours,
how well would it do in your classes?
So, well, GPT-5 isn't out yet,
so I don't think any of us knows
quite what it's gonna be able to do.
But there's a really deep question there,
which is the many of
the classes that I teach
or at least the main NLP class
is all about doing original research.
And the question of to
what extent these models
are able to produce
original ideas of their own,
to what extent they're
just remixing things
that they saw in the training data
is still like I guess
many of the other things
that we've talked about today,
a big open scientific question.
So I suspect right now,
GPT-4 maybe even GPT-5
is not gonna be great
at coming up with an implementing
and new NLP projects, but who knows?
Okay, I think that's all we have time for,
so thanks very much for
listening and see you later.